So, our setup link.
>> There we go.
>> And I've become a huge fan of this little search box.
>> Oh man, life before that search box was really rough.
>> Who wants to navigate all this nonsense arrows and business?
Alright, so chatter. Chatter mobile, new. Is that what we're doing?
>> No.
[LAUGH]
Under build > Chatter, and then Feed Tracking.
>> Okay.
>> Okay, so just to give you a brief synopsis
of what we're looking at, this is showing you all of
the different objects that you have within your org. Both
the standard objects that are included, and the stuff we've created.
>> Mm hmm.
>> Now what we want to do, is we want to enable our stage
object for feed tracking, so that people can collaborate on a stage record.
>> Okay.
>> And so what this means, Enable for Feed Tracking,
means it's going to put a Chatter feed at
the top of our stage record, for people
to either follow the record if they want
to or just, you know, make post-songs record.
>> Okay.
>> So, we want to look for the stage object over here.
>> Stage, over here?
>> Yep. And so if we enable this for feed tracking.
>> Mm-hm.
>> We can also select whatever fields we want to
show up in the feed if they were to change.
>> Okay.
>> Like for example, if we were to choose the stage manager field.
If we checked the stage manager field, whenever the stage manager gets changed.
>>
[CROSSTALK]
Mm-hm.
>> Or reassigned. That's going to automatically post to
the chatter feed, hey, the stage manager's changed from.
[CROSSTALK]
>> Cool.
>> Blah to blah.
>> Okay, so, I don't know let's follow the stage manager.
And if the size of the stage changes, he'd want to know.
>> Yeah.
>> I don't really think anything else would change enough to need it.
>> That looks good to me and then just click
Save. So you can configure this for any of the
objects in your organization if you say, just want to
get updated or collaborate on any of your custom schema.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay
so we've enabled Chatter. What can I do now? Go back to stage?
>> Yeah, let's go back to the Stage Record.